tell me what democracy it looks like
for 60 days portland has protested for
black lives matter
a few weeks ago just 100 or so people
were still turning out
but after federal troops arrive to
restore order
they've taken to the streets in their
thousands
the world is watching us so i feel like
donald trump is sending all these troops
in here
to antagonize on purpose and what he's
trying to do
is he's trying to roll us up if he can
do it in a 75
white state then he can do it in chicago
he can do it in new york
he can do it in atlanta so
as portlanders we need to keep it
peaceful and we need to remember
that democracy is hanging in the balance
for two weeks the peaceful protest has
been overshadowed by
nightly violence between a minority and
police
in response donald trump tweeted the
protesters are actually anarchists who
hate our country
the line of innocent mothers were a scam
that lame stream refuses to acknowledge
just like they don't report the violence
of these demonstrations
portland mums dressed in yellow have
been turning out in their hundreds since
last
saturday forming a human wall between
the courthouse
and protesters i mean this is what you
have to do it doesn't matter how busy
anybody is
how long are you going to keep
protesting for i'm not going to stop
like this is this is it's time for a
change
right now in the latest protest the mums
have shared their wall with military
veterans
who formed their own group four days ago
i'm not even the one being oppressed but
i'm just i don't like it in my city
i'm proud of portland and i'm ashamed of
it right now and i'm shaved to the
of the feds coming in and really
they don't belong here before any
obvious sign of unrest
tear gas was unexpectedly thrown from
above
peaceful protesters dispersed and most
left
a standoff followed and the now nightly
violence between agents
and those remaining
deployment to other u.s cities has now
sparked similar protests and violence
a growing standoff between two sides
with radically different views
sally lockwood sky news portland